[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily
walmart takes on kanye west as a battle
over brand logos heats up
and the department of justice launching
a civil investigation into the
louisville kentucky police department
more than a year after the shooting
death of brianna taylor
the investigation will be led by our
civil rights division
plus the family of andrew brown sees the
sheriff's office body cam footage of his
death
but should it be made public and the
state of maryland to review the former
work of a key defense expert
in the derek chovin trial following his
testimony
why retired medical examiner dr david
fowler's handling of in-custody deaths
is now being questioned lawn crime daily
covering court cases from coast to coast
welcome to long crime daily everybody
i'm jesse weber in for brian buckmeyer
along with co-host terry austin
maryland's attorney general is calling
for a review of cases involving a key
defense witness in derek shovin's trial
long crimes anjanet levy explains why
the deaths to be reviewed
involve people who've died in police
custody
dr david fowler was the chief medical
examiner for the state of maryland for
17 years
following his testimony for the defense
in the trial of derrick chauvin
the attorney general for the state of
maryland says he believes that some of
fowler's work
needs to be reviewed his
significant contributory conditions
would be
the toxicology the fentanyl and
methamphetamine
there is exposure to a vehicle exhaust
dr fowler mentioning vehicle exhaust and
his opinion that george floyd's manner
of death
should be classified undetermined and
not homicide
raised eyebrows it prompted this letter
signed by physicians demanding a review
of fowler's work
calling the open-air carbon monoxide
exposure claim baseless
and revealed obvious bias and raised
malpractice concerns
fowler's opinion ran contrary to the
pathologist who conducted floyd's
autopsy
well it's a pattern in practice attorney
ken ravenel
claims dr fowler provides cover to
police when someone dies in custody
he represents the family of anton black
in a federal lawsuit
black died in 2019 after being
handcuffed and restrained by officers
dr fowler ruled the death an accident
why does dr following
his team constantly ignore the obvious
to try to search for other reasons
that has to we have to put a stop to
this maryland attorney general brian
frosh released a statement saying he's
been in conversations with governor
larry hogan's office
about the need for a review of dr
fowler's findings the ag's office
represents dr fowler and
others in the black lawsuit a
spokesperson said
we have taken steps to wall off those in
our office who are representing the
office of chief medical examiner
and its current and former employees
including dr fowler
from those who might be involved in any
review of the medical examiner's reports
the attorney for anton black's family
says this review has been a long time
coming
while dr fowler actually released a
statement through his employer
saying he stands behind the outstanding
work that his staff performed
during his time as chief medical
examiner for law and crime daily
i'm angenette levy all right thanks ange
joining us is legal analyst
dina dahl along with terry austin so
terry sounds like the aeg is going to
take a close look at these past
medical reports if discrepancies are
found could dr fowler face charges
he could jesse you know he definitely
could lose his license that's a big
issue here
but what they're looking for is a
pattern of bias and if they find that he
might lose his license they can even
find
gross negligence they've talked about
that or even fraud and that would be a
bigger issue
as angenette reported we know that he's
being sued by antoine black's
family and so if they find that he was
you know culpable there he could face a
lot of
financial problems in that suit dina let
me ask you this
if fowler's conclusions that they come
out as problematic
could derek chauvin rely on that in an
appeal and say hey look ineffective
assistant
ineffective assistance of counsel eric
nelson why did you choose this guy from
my defense
probably not and the reason why if there
is some sort of bias
it's in favor of the police and stopping
here was acting as a police officer so
that would mean his bias
was actually favorable to him so that
would have
helped him in his defense not hurt him
in his defense
and also it was reasonable for his
lawyer to rely on him he is
right now in private practice and his
opinion
was actually a collaboration of about 13
experts done
under a private practice opinion so
he would not have a leg to stand on in
this regard for the appeal
well there's going to be a microscope on
dr fowler's work it'll be interesting to
see the outcome of what ultimately
happens
now back to derek chovin he is going to
be sentenced on june
16th and in the meantime he's being held
in state prison
so we asked psychologist and long crime
expert dr john de la tour
what time behind bars might feel like
for the ex-cop
uh devastating i mean here he was
someone that had the authority someone
that had the power someone that had a
badge
who at some point in his life thought
that he was doing the right thing and
protecting
society only now to be in a place where
other people that he knows other people
might try to hurt him that he has to be
moved away and kept in a
segregated the clinks of the bars i mean
just just that sound just repeatedly
over and over and over again
absolutely is so much of a toll on
on a former police officer i think at
this point now he needs to
he needs to humanize himself he decided
not to do it during the trial
and that makes sense but now it's
sentencing time and now
you know how much time he serves in
prison is going to be
based on a lot of different factors and
i'm thinking the judge probably wants to
hear from him too to see
is he contrite right is he someone that
understands
the the authority that he had the role
that he played
and is he sorry for what he did
reality for derrick chauvin still ahead
on long crime
daily a north carolina family is looking
for answers after andrew brown was shot
and killed by deputies trying to arrest
him
but first u.s attorney general merrick
garland is launching an investigation
into the death of brianna taylor
we'll break that date we'll break that
case down on the other side of this
break
stay tuned
the department of justice is launching a
civil investigation into the louisville
kentucky government and police
department
following the death of brianna taylor
taylor was killed last march after
officers executed a no-knock warrant in
her home
former officer brett hankinson is facing
charges for shooting into taylor's
neighbor's apartment
but no one is charged in her death
federal investigators are already
looking into possible additional
criminal charges
now the city and police department could
be civilly
liable the investigation will assess
whether lmpd engages in a pattern or
practice
of using unregu un reasonable
force including with respect to people
involved in peaceful
expressive activities it will determine
whether
lmpd engages in unconstitutional stops
searches and seizures as well as whether
the department unlawfully executes
search warrants
on private homes it will also assess
whether lmpd
engages in discriminatory conduct on the
basis of race
or fails to provide public services that
comply
with the americans with disability act
so terry this is the second time in less
than a week that a.g garland has an
announced investigation
into the pattern and practices of a
police department of course i'm talking
about minneapolis
is this an indication of things to come
absolutely jesse there's no question in
my mind
garland is really going to try to make
sure that the police departments across
the country
are acting without bias so now you see
first minneapolis then louisville and i
can guarantee you that he's probably
going to look
into the shooting of andrew brown
in elizabeth city north carolina because
there are so many questions
about that video so i think that he is
going to think about each and every case
that we've seen across the country
in the past few years where there has
been no charge and no indictment and no
prosecution
and he will look at the pattern in
practice in all of those departments
you know terry you mentioned north
carolina let's talk about that for a
second because another family is
struggling to get answers
and as you said it's in the fatal
shooting of a man by deputies
last week andrew brown was killed as
deputies in elizabeth city attempted to
serve him with an arrest warrant
his family and attorney were able to
view the sheriff's office police body
cam
footage on monday they say the 20
seconds of video shows deputies blocked
in his car blocking him in his car
and he had his hands on the steering
wheel when he tried to get away from the
deputies who were shooting
now few details have been released but a
death certificate says that brown
died from a gunshot wound to the head
the sheriff says that he supports the
video being released publicly
if a judge permits
we want transparency we want the body
camera footage
made public some people have falsely
claimed
that my office has the power to do so
that is not true
only a judge can release the video
that's why i've asked the north carolina
state bureau of investigation to confirm
for me
that the releasing of the video will not
undermine
their investigation once i get that
confirmation
our county will file a motion in court
hopefully monday
to have the footage released
okay let's break it down dina the
chances that this video this footage
actually gets released to the public and
we all see it
i think it's a very good chance and you
see here what he's saying
he needs confirmation and release of it
is not going to impede an investigation
if he get he does not get that he will
not file the motion to the court asking
for it obviously there aren't privacy
concerns the family
wants this to be released this will be
released
will there be any sort of delay because
of the investigation
that's really unclear it sounds like it
really is based on whether or not that
department
is going to tell the judge if it needs
any time before releasing it
terry there's something a bit confusing
here because the family is filing a
court order to view the body cam footage
but in
other jurisdictions the footage is just
automatically released
should that be the uniform procedure
across the country
absolutely we should get as many uniform
procedures across the country as we can
you know that the george floyd policing
act was passed in the house it's still
pending as far as the senate is
concerned
there's only so much that we can do on a
federal level
they can't really control what each
police department is doing
although they can have certain mandates
like no chokeholds
but what we are seeing is that the
attorney general
is looking at these patterns and
practices and perhaps we will have
consent decrees
with these various cities so that most
of them will be doing things
like showing the video cam from the
bodies of the police officers so
hopefully it'll be more uniform
it'll be important to view that body cam
footage by everyone
and coming up on long crime daily wanted
on federal charges for
failing to return a vhs tape two decades
ago
we're gonna tell you about one texas
woman's story plus a father's outrage as
his son's alleged murderer files for a
new defense
why a former miami security guard chose
to represent himself
at trial next
[Music]
welcome back everybody a miami security
guard was accused of fatally shooting a
man at a strip club
long crime founder and host of the a e
series court cam dan abrams
explains the family of the victim became
outraged as they learned the defense's
strategy
we're in the miami-dade county criminal
court for a hearing related to the
murder trial of lucas kendall
well the first thing we needed to
address is he's been restored to
competency
correct toronto there are two
evaluations from dr
ruiz quintana and dr richardson they
both find that he's confident
kendall's just been deemed competent to
stand trial
where he faces charges of second-degree
murder and attempted murder
while working as an armed security guard
at a miami strip club
kendall approached two men who were
sitting inside a truck in the parking
lot
kendall claims one of the men threatened
him he says he also believed one of them
had a weapon
so he opened fire killing one of them
with eight shots
four of them in the back both men
were unarmed
in the gallery today our friends and
family of the deceased victim
kawan burr including his devastated
parents
to evaluate his competency kendall was
moved from a prison to a hospital
and defense attorney carlos gonzalez
wants to keep him there
fearing what might become of his
client's mental state if he returns to
jail
and then the issue is that you want him
how
where at the same facility he's been
housed in order to
prevent him from decompensating yes he
eventually decompensated to the point
where he was sitting in a fetal position
naked not eating and not interacting
with any human being
as gonzales goes on the request to
prevent kendall from returning to jail
becomes just too much for bird's father
to bear
my son man he needs to go to prison
he don't need to be landing
he needs to go man come on let's go
he wasn't he wasn't crazy
the distraught father's escorted out of
the courtroom as family members look on
meanwhile the defendant just watches it
all unfold
at trial kendall decided to represent
himself
and attempted to use the stand your
ground defense
so the trajectory coming from outside
the vehicle would have to come
in that downward i'm sorry i'm not sure
what you're referring to
he was convicted on both charges and is
now serving a life sentence in the
florida prison system
wow core cam airs wednesdays on the a
e networks when we come back kanye west
facing more legal trouble is his cup is
his clothing company's logo
too similar to a logo from a retail
giant the arguments on the other side
of this break
[Music]
the criminal case against jeffrey
epstein's ex-girlfriend glean maxwell is
growing as
prosecutors now charge her with sex
trafficking
the former socialite faced her judge in
person for the first time to plead not
guilty
to two new charges a federal grand jury
indicted maxwell last month for sex
trafficking prosecutors say she groomed
and paid a 14 year old girl to engage in
sex acts with epstein at his palm beach
home from 2001
to 2004 this indictment adds a fourth
victim
and expands the time frame of the
allegations
maxwell's lawyers are requesting a delay
in her trial
which was set for july 12 of this year
due to the additional charges
well kanye west is in hot water but not
from his soon-to-be ex-wife kim
kardashian walmart is
suing the yeezy brand over its sunburst
or spark logo saying it's just too
similar to theirs the big box store is
also claiming that west llc
offers quote highly related and directly
overlapping services like apparel
walmart wants to make it clear that they
do not have a relationship with easy
attorneys for walmart filed a notice of
opposition to the yeezy corporation's
application for a trademark of its logo
all right so let's talk about this uh
dina the likelihood
that wes just drops the logo he goes
with something else he's a creative guy
or do you think he'll actually fight
this what benefit does he have to fight
it
if he fights it i think he will
eventually lose because walmart has had
this logo since 2007 so it's a valid
pre-existing logo
and it does look like there is some
overlap especially walmart's position
that
these days they have partnerships with
celebrities
and that makes it even more confusing
we've seen the mashup of the logo with
gaff and yeezy and so there is some sort
of customer confusion not only with the
image
but the fact that is there a question of
this being its own
mash-up so if he pursues it i think he
will ultimately lose
you know it looks pretty similar but
walmart's claiming this trademark
infringement
terry is that how likelihood
can you get to win that i mean how tough
is it to prevail on that claim
well i actually think i agree with deana
here they could prevail what the u.s
patent and trademark office says
is that you have to have a valid mark
meaning that it was registered or that
you've been using it
and you have to have used it prior to
when the defendant used it so
we clearly know that walmart had the
mark first
and then they have to show that there's
some likelihood of confusion
and they can cause that with real people
who have actually been confused they can
submit
some sort of evidence saying these
individuals were confused or they can
just say look we think it will likely
cause confusion so if they can do that i
think that walmart will prevail and i
think that
he's going to have to use another mark
that doesn't look exactly like
this sun logo and perhaps you know he
can
go in another direction i don't know
more drama with kanye west
over how to texas where a woman found
out that she was wanted on
federal embezzlement charges in oklahoma
for
failing to return a vhs tape in 1999.
karen mcbride is pleading not guilty for
forgetting to return
sabrina the teenage witch tape saying
she didn't even remember
renting the video she learned about the
charges while trying to change her name
after she got married in texas
meanwhile the movie palace in norman
oklahoma where mcbride rented the vhs
tape from
that closed in 2008. now the cleveland
county district court has
dropped the charges but in order to
clear her record
mcbride needs her case expunged
so dina pretty hilarious pretty
incredible this happened how come no one
came after her before
well i think one thing that helped her
was that she moved she was
in texas instead of oklahoma if she had
ever gotten stopped for
some sort of speeding ticket and they
did a search of her name they would have
seen that there was this arrest warrant
out there but the fact that she was no
longer in the same state
she must have not had any interaction
with police this was a misdemeanor they
weren't going to start crossing state
lines
looking for her so i think that really
delayed her
um getting served with this war now
terry the charges were dropped but the
record hasn't been expunged what does it
take to expunge a record
well you know it's always something
jessie but to expunge the record
actually takes a little bit of
effort on her part she's going to
actually
have to file a petition to get it
expunged expunged means
it's completely and totally utterly
destroyed that no one will ever see a
piece of paper so the arrest record
you know if there's any sort of
indictment any sort of criminal record
will
actually be expunged but the judge has
to look at that petition
has to consider all of the information
and then he has to actually or she has
to actually
make a decision as to whether or not
this can be expunged
and the judge will look at lots of
various factors i don't know i just look
at this and i kind of miss
vhs tapes that's what i take away from
this uh dina terry i appreciate you
coming on breaking this all down with me
thanks for joining us here on law and
crime daily we'll see you next time as
we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
you